my name is JM longoria
and so I worked on the directed by
peddler unfortunately going to be here
tonight portugal said he'll come out
here represent our zone so it's a short
film where love and creativity meet and
it questions whether a regular cup of
coffee is enough to capture the
attention of a pretty good
well its regular it's really regular guy
to coffee shop you see the girl walking
rushed it works there NT that kind of
both love coffee and she says they be
able to procreate
maybe it's a really really cute short
and it's actually based on an experience
in the director petrol had in his life
and it's been doing really well it's
been you know premiering in various
festivals around
very happy to be here representing skull
what's your take on that if you were to
put yourself in the shoes of that what's
really wonderful about it is that it's a
silent films it's just all based on
reacts to music and it's it's amazing
how much editing and acting it was
actually came out a great example
and how are they spreading the word
about the film well there you have a
website www WMA be short com you can see
a trailer on there you'll be closing it
up soon somebody's continue you can see
pictures of the production and you have
a Twitter
Twitter and Facebook yeah